6 juin 1944.
Un jour gris se lève sur la Manche,
dévoilant un spectacle sidérant.
Jamais on n'avait vu pareille armada
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Sur 7 000 navires, 130 000 hommes
traversent la Manche
sous la couverture de 20 000 avions.
Au petit matin, après un déluge de feu,
les hommes vont débarquer
sur les côtes de France.
20 000 d'entre eux arrivent aussi
par la voie des airs.
10 500 soldats alliés perdus ce jour-là.
Et presque autant du côté allemand.
Onze semaine plus tard,
Paris sera libéré
et la route de Berlin ouverte.
Ce film nous racontera,
côté alliés et côté allemand,
cette gigantesque épopée.
Depuis sa préparation
en Angleterre dès janvier 44.
Jusqu'à son aboutissement durant l'été.
Avec les généraux
américains Dwight Eisenhower,
Omar Bradley,
l'Anglais Bernard Montgomery,
le Premier ministre
britannique Winston Churchill,
le maréchal allemand Erwin Rommel.
Et puis aussi bien sûr, tous les héros,
souvent anonymes,
qui ont fait ce débarquement.
Sans oublier certains hommes,
tel le sergent Grant,
qui l'ont filmé au péril de leur vie.
Tous ensemble,
ils ont participé à ce fabuleux événement
qui, contrairement à la légende,
ne fut pas une marche triomphante.
1ᵉʳ décembre 1943,
Conférence de Téhéran.
Trois chefs d'État
viennent de prendre une décision capitale.
Le maréchal Staline, dirigeant
de la puissante Russie prend place,
satisfait en haut des marches,
devant le Premier
ministre britannique Churchill, soucieux,
quelques marches plus bas.
Depuis deux ans, Staline, Churchill
et Roosevelt, le président des États-Unis,
bataillent pour se mettre d'accord
sur la date de ce débarquement
à l'ouest de l'Europe.
Le sort de la guerre et du monde
vont en dépendre.
Dès l'entrée en guerre de son pays
contre l'Allemagne en juin 1941,
le soviétique réclamait l'ouverture
d'un second front à l'Ouest,
destiné à soulager la pression sur
ses troupes, seules à l'est face à Hitler.
De leur côté,
sous l'influence de Churchill
qui craignait
d'attaquer l'Allemagne de front,
les Anglo-Américains
avaient vainement espéré l'abattre
en passant
par l'Afrique du Nord.
Pour l'envahir depuis
le sud de l'Europe via l'Italie.
Mais ils avaient été bloqués
à hauteur de Naples.
Sans plus pouvoir avancer
vers l'Allemagne.
Longtemps, Roosevelt
s'était montré hésitant.
Il estimait que son pays n'était pas prêt
pour cette immense opération
et désormais, il veut en finir
au plus vite avec le Reich
et le vaincre en Europe de l'Ouest.
Roosevelt souhaite aussi coopérer
avec les Soviétiques après la victoire.
Churchill n'a plus qu'à se résigner.
Depuis l'entrée en guerre
des États-Unis en 1941,
Hitler redoutait une invasion
sur les côtes ouest de l'Europe
occupées par les Allemands.
Dès 1942, il s'était attelé
à une tâche gigantesque.
Construire un mur le long de l'Atlantique,
constitué d'un ensemble continu
de fortifications sur 6 000 kilomètres,
de la Norvège à la frontière espagnole.
Même si les Allemands
ont soupçonné les Alliés
de vouloir débarquer
dans le Pas-de-Calais,
distant de 40 kilomètres
seulement des côtes anglaises.
Les autorités allemandes avaient donc
réquisitionné des milliers d'hommes,
travailleurs libres,
requis du S.T.O, réfugiés,
juifs, prisonniers de guerre,
pour mener à bien
cette construction délirante
qui nécessitera plus de
13 millions de tonnes de béton.
Décidément, cette fin d'année 1943,
la forteresse Europe
semble solidement aux mains des Allemands.
Le 15 janvier 1944,
choisi par Roosevelt pour diriger
le débarquement,
Ike Eisenhower arrive à Londres
pour aussitôt préparer l'opération.
Elle porte le nom d'Overlord,
suzerain, en français,
la reine de toutes les batailles.
Des mesures ont été prises
pour le début d'une grande et décisive
épreuve à travers le monde.
[English spoken audio]
Je sais que les soldats, marins et pilotes
et toutes les populations civiles
des Nations Unies,
démontreront une fois pour toutes
qu'une démocratie vivante
est la plus formidable force de combat
que l'on puisse concevoir.
Quelques jours plus tard, Ike
présente son équipe à la presse.
L'Américain Eisenhower,
nommé commandant en chef,
son second se doit d'être britannique.
Il a donc nommé responsable
de toutes les forces terrestres,
le général Montgomery dit Monti,
héros de la guerre d'Afrique contre Rommel
et enfant chéri des Britanniques.
Les militaires ont déjà leur plan,
mais rien ne doit être révélé.
Plutôt poser pour la presse devant une
carte aussi défraîchie qu'illisible.
Tout ce petit cirque
n'empêche pas Montgomery
de se mettre déjà sous les sunlight,
plus sensible aux caméras
qu'aux gesticulations de ses collègues.
En réalité, par delà leur embrouillamini,
les militaires ont déjà choisi
la France pour débarquer.
En Normandie plutôt que
dans le Pas-de-Calais.
Car si la côte normande
est plus éloignée de l'Angleterre,
elle est en revanche moins défendue.
L'assaut aura lieu au printemps,
entre Ouistreham
et Carentan, à la base du Cotentin.
Montgomery a tenu
à élargir la ligne de front jusqu'à Caen.
Pour ne pas être coincé
sur un trop petit périmètre
le long des plages.
Il a aussi voulu étendre
le front plus à l'Ouest
pour se rapprocher du port
en eaux profondes de Cherbourg,
dont il faudra très vite s'emparer,
pour assurer
la logistique d'une puissante armée.
Le secret est vital si l'on veut réussir.
Les Allemands doivent tout ignorer
du plan des Alliés.
Et en ce début 44,
ils ignorent toujours quand
et où le débarquement se produira.
Raison de plus pour faire sonner
les grosses caisses de la propagande.
[German spoken audio]
L'arrivée d'Eisenhower à Londres
a cependant confirmé Hitler
dans ses craintes
d'une invasion à l'Ouest.
En 1942, il avait nommé maréchal l'un
de ses plus brillants généraux,
le populaire Erwin Rommel.
À la tête de l'Africakorps,
le renard du désert
avait donné bien du mal aux Anglais.
C'est donc naturellement que le Führer
charge cet énergique guerrier
de renforcer encore les défenses
de la forteresse Europe.
Début 1944, Rommel est en France.
L'aviation nazie mobilisée en Allemagne
contre les bombardements alliés,
il ne pourra guère l'utiliser
en Normandie.
Tout se jouera donc à terre
et sur les plages
qu'ils jugent mal protégées.
Il désire établir
une ligne de défense continue
en comblant les trous
entre les points fortifiés.
Parallèlement, le maréchal demande
d'intensifier le minage du littoral.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'une mine ?
Une goutte d'eau dans la mer en regard
des 1 200 kilomètres de côtes françaises
qui s'étendent du Pas-de-Calais
à la base de la Basse Bretagne.
L'énergie déployée par Rommel
n'alarme guère Eisenhower,
car depuis des mois, les Anglo-Américains
construisent en Grande-Bretagne
des ports artificiels qui évitent d'avoir
un vrai port à prendre,
et leur laisse toute latitude
pour choisir le lieu de leur attaque.
Cette tâche titanesque
n'effraie pas les Alliés.
À voir ces phœnix,
énormes caissons de béton,
destinés à être remorqués un jour
jusqu'à la côte normande
où ils seront coulés pour constituer
une première digue brise lames.
Plateformes
où seront déversés des tonnes de matériel
ainsi que les hommes par milliers,
avant qu'elles ne soit arrimées
aux immenses ponts métalliques
qui permettront d'accéder aux plages,
quelle que soit la hauteur des marées.
Gigantesque puzzle en train
d'être rassemblé
dans de nombreux ports d'Angleterre.
En Grande-Bretagne,
les entraînements se poursuivent.
Britanniques et Américains
font feu de tout bois,
même si encore devant des caméras.
Balai aquatique et effet pyrotechnique
sont aussi de mise.
Le matériel aussi est testé.
Chars anti-mines pour dégager les plages.
Tapis rigide pour en sortir.
Gymkhana sur vagues en dur
en pour s'habituer à la conduite
de ces nouvelles Jeep venues d'Amérique.
Sans oublier ces nouveaux chars crocodiles
qui doivent passer au feu
tout ce qui n'aura pas été réduit
en cendres sous les bombardements.
Les Alliés ont déjà perdu
des centaines d'hommes
à l'entraînement en Grande-Bretagne.
Alors pourquoi choisir encore un tel site
si sauvage en pleine Cornouailles?
Même si le quatrième commando britannique
est déjà une unité aguerrie.
Parce qu'il faut envisager toutes
les topographies de terrains possibles.
C'est connu, l'oncle Sam
ne se lance jamais dans une bataille
tant que le rapport de force
ne lui est pas éminemment favorable.
Venus de l'Utah, du Kansas,
de l'Ohio, du Kentucky,
ces jeunes boys qui arrivent,
savent-ils seulement
où se trouvent la France et l'Angleterre ?
Pressentent-ils l'enfer
qui les attend sur les plages normandes ?
En février 44,
plus de 800 000 soldats américains
sont déjà en Grande-Bretagne.
Les hommes continuent d'affluer.
Tout de suite
un certain parfum d'Angleterre
avec l'incontournable petit beignet.
Première gâterie
et peut-être bientôt plus si affinités.
L'Amérique continue aussi
de déverser son matériel.
À l'instar de ces tanks Sherman,
appelés à se confronter
aux redoutables panzers de la Wehrmacht.
Tandis que pubs
et petites villes grises d'Angleterre
découvrent ces nouveaux chasseurs
bombardiers P-38
dont l'autonomie et le rayon d'action
surclassent ceux des avions anglais.
Il n'est pas toujours facile
de céder la place aux nouveaux arrivants,
qu'il faut bien loger quelque part,
quitte à faire évacuer les habitants
sous le regard triste des familles.
Et les stéréotypes ont la vie dure
entre pauvre bougre d'Angleterre
et ses cousins gâtés d'Amérique.
Ne serait-ce qu'à cause de leur solde
et ration infiniment supérieure
à celle de leurs parents britanniques
plus démunis.
Un élément pourtant va faire le lien.
Comme ici par exemple à Blackpool,
jolie station balnéaire,
où les permissions
accordées aux soldats américains
et l'intérêt que leur portent
la gente féminine
risquent fort de se terminer
par le plaisir de tout le monde.
Sauf peut-être pour les maris absents.
Jamais au royaume de Sa Majesté,
les divorces et les enfants illégitimes
n'auront été si nombreux
que durant cette période.
Mais à la guerre comme à la guerre.
Et vive les petites anglaises !
La fraternité était à l'ordre du jour
et tout indique que les choses
se déroulent comme prévu.
Il n'y a pas que le bebop
pour rapprocher les cœurs.
Le général Eisenhower
a toujours respecté ses alliés.
En mars, il rend visite à la prestigieuse
école d'officiers de Sandhurst.
Celle-là même où le jeune Churchill
avait fait ses classes.
Et Ike entend bien dire à ces cadets
ce qu'il attend d'eux.
- [English spoken audio] Vous,
jeunes hommes devez gagner cette guerre.
Il vous revient
de mener vos troupes,
qu'il s'agisse d'un équipage de tank,
d'un peloton ou d'une compagnie,
à chaque heure de la journée,
chaque jour de la semaine.
Vous devez connaître
chacun de vos hommes.
Il ne suffit pas d'être
le meilleur soldat de votre unité,
le plus fort, le plus coriace,
le plus résistant,
le mieux équipé techniquement.
Vous devez être leur chef,
leur père, leur mentor.
Ainsi, vous aurez accompli votre devoir
et vous aurez été dignes
des traditions de cette grande école
et de votre pays.
Ils ont tous 20 ans ces jeunes Anglais
auxquels Ike s'est adressé
avec son humanité habituelle.
Sachant que nombre d'entre
eux mourront bientôt.
Fidèles représentants d'un pays
qui depuis quatre ans maintenant,
résiste aux nazis.
Ce même mois de mars,
alors que le grand jour se rapproche,
c'est au tour de Churchill
d'assister à l'entraînement grandeur
nature d'une unité parachutiste américaine
sous les yeux d'Ike lui-même.
Les actualités cinématographiques
anglaises ne s'y sont pas trompées.
Elles aussi ont décidé de faire les choses
en grand avec leur caméra embarquée.
À un cigare près, on pourrait s'y croire.
Même l'homme au cigare
a droit à sa caméra.
Avec le sourire en prime.
Bon nombre de cinéastes
utiliseront à l'avenir ces images
pour mettre en scène le premier largage
des Américains sur le Cotentin,
jamais filmé en réalité.
Plus important, le chapeau de Churchill,
désormais totalement engagé
dans l'opération Overlord
malgré toutes ses réticences initiales.
Si les alliés sont unis
et rassemblés en Angleterre,
Hitler est loin des opérations
dans son QG de l'Est, près du front russe.
Pire, fidèle à son habitude,
il divise pour mieux régner.
À l'Ouest, il a fractionné
le commandement allemand
entre le maréchal Von Runstedt,
chef de tout le front occidental,
et le maréchal Rommel,
responsable des défenses côtières.
Or les deux hommes sont en désaccord.
Rundstedt veut garder
ses divisions blindées
à l'intérieur des terres pour pouvoir
faire converger toutes ses forces
vers les zones précises
où auront débarqué les Alliés.
Rommel, lui, pense que l'aviation alliée
paralysera les mouvements de ses troupes.
Il veut donc déjà répartir les blindés
au plus près des rives
pour rejeter l'ennemi à la mer
sitôt débarqué.
Mais il n'obtient pas
gain de cause.
Dès lors, il se concentre plus que jamais
sur la protection des plages
et dresse des obstacles anti-char.
Il exige aussi l'installation de barrières
anti barge et de chevaux de frise
constitués de morceaux de rails
formant de redoutables obstacles.
Il s'attaque même
à la géographie du terrain
afin d'empêcher les parachutages alliés
et leurs mouvements de troupes.
Quand ils le peuvent, les Allemands
inondent l'intérieur des terres côtières.
Région du Devon,
au Sud-Ouest de l'Angleterre,
où l'infanterie américaine
s'exerce à débarquer
sur une plage au pied d'une falaise
où l'ennemi pourrait être posté.
Dès lors, vite se mettre
à l'abri de la paroi
pour y installer tout de suite la radio
destinée à informer ceux qui suivront.
Creuser afin de se mettre à l'abri.
Mais si tu tiens à ta peau
sous le feu ennemi,
sans doute, jeune soldat,
devras-tu y mettre un peu plus d'ardeur.
Attendre le moment propice
pour récupérer ton matériel
et secourir les blessés.
Et si le jour venu la plage de galets
était impossible à creuser ?
Si la marée basse
obligeait à plus se découvrir
avant d'atteindre les blessés ?
Comme sur la future plage d'Omaha,
si semblable à celle du Devon,
mais où les Américains
perdront 3 000 hommes.
Si cette plage ressemble tant
à celle sur laquelle les boys
débarqueront un jour,
c'est que les alliés n'ignorent plus rien
des plages qu'ils vont envahir.
Depuis des semaines, souvent renseignés
par la Résistance française
au prix d'une sévère répression,
les Alliés mitraillent à coups de photos
l'ensemble des installations allemandes.
Sites protégés ou non,
les côtes de la Manche
sont passées au peigne fin.
Tout y est systématiquement
repéré, répertorié.
Les renseignements collectés
et mis en forme,
leurs données sont ensuite intégrées
au plan d'attaque des Alliés.
Bien sûr, toujours secret.
Sauf peut-être pour les Allemands
qui risquent de crouler
sous les informations,
ou plutôt sous les désinformations.
Depuis des mois,
les services de renseignement alliés
abreuvent l'ennemi
de fausses informations
destinées à le leurrer
sur les lieux du débarquement,
en lui suggérant
que l'option Pas-de-Calais a été retenue.
Sur le sol anglais,
l'intoxication aussi est de mise.
Avoir installé face aux côtes
du nord de la France de faux aérodromes
où fleurissent des avions gonflables.
Tandis qu'au sud de l'Angleterre,
où les principales forces sont disséminées
approvisionnements, armes et munitions
continuent d'être camouflés.
En mai, cependant,
on ne peut plus dissimuler
l'énormité des moyens mis en œuvre.
Des centaines de milliers d'hommes
sont maintenant regroupés dans des camps
afin de les rapprocher
de leur lieu d'embarquement
et de les isoler des populations
pour éviter les fuites.
En avant, en arrière !
Mais l'encadrement ne néglige pas
le moral des troupes,
quitte à mettre un bémol
à une discipline tatillonne.
Dans cette escadre de la RF par exemple,
où il ne faudrait pas briser
les ailes des aviateurs
avant même qu'ils ne s'envolent
pour casser les reins de quelques Boches
en pleine campagne normande.
Au milieu des hommes
est bien sûr invisible
il y a aussi ceux qui filment
auquel on ne pense jamais.
Tous élèves de l'école de cinéma
de l'armée anglaise et tous volontaires
chargés de témoigner pour nous
de l'immense événement qui se prépare.
Le plus jeune d'entre eux,
Desmond O'Neill, 20 ans.
Il compte bien couvrir le grand jour.
Comme ses collègues,
il a été nommé sergent d'office,
grade idéal pour rester proche des hommes.
« Ma caméra était la bienvenue,
elle les distrayait », dira O'Neill.
Ce 27 mai, ses camarades font connaissance
avec de nouveaux billets.
Ces francs français
imprimés par les Alliés
qui mettront
le général de Gaulle en fureur.
Il y verra une atteinte
à la souveraineté de la France,
seule habilitée à frapper sa monnaie.
Mais pour l'instant,
il est tenu à l'écart.
Et même, il ignore tout
de ce qui se prépare.
« Ces hommes savaient
qu'ils risquaient fort d'être tués. »
« Cela créait une atmosphère étrange ».
Ajoutera encore O'Neill.
Autre caméraman des armées,
le sergent Ian Grant, 27 ans,
toujours avec son béret écossais.
Il a choisi le service cinématographique
pour échapper aux corvées
et immortaliser ses camarades.
Ce 31 mai, Ian
les montre recevoir le livret
qui les informe sur le pays inconnu
qu'ils s'apprêtent à envahir.
« C'est dans ce camp qu'on a su
pour la première fois »
« que notre objectif
serait la Normandie », dira-t-il.
Il pointe aussi les
quelques denrées supplémentaires
auxquelles ont droit des hommes
qui se préparent à affronter le pire.
Car désormais,
ce n'est plus qu'une question de jours.
1ᵉʳ juin, Norman Clague,
l'homme qui ne nous a malheureusement
laissé que son clap,
nous montre les dernières instructions
données à sa compagnie.
Il filme de haut comme s'il aimait déjà
prendre des risques.
Mais ici, c'est pour ne pas dévoiler
le lieu où ses camarades débarqueront.
Eux-mêmes ne savent
sans doute pas très bien
où se trouve Ouistreham en Normandie.
Tout est secret.
C'est pour cela qu'ils sont à l'isolement
depuis deux semaines.
Désormais les dés sont jetés
pour Clague et les siens,
qui maintenant partent pour les ports,
début de leur grande aventure.
Les Américains parfaitement équipés
ne sont pas en reste.
Avec leur 1 500 000 hommes,
ils sont désormais plus nombreux
sur le sol d'Angleterre
que leurs frères d'armes britanniques.
Début juin,
des centaines de milliers d'hommes
quittent leur camp
sous les yeux d'une population
venue saluer ces nouveaux braves.
Tous affluent
vers leur lieu d'embarquement,
les 19 ports au sud de l'Angleterre.
Tandis que les Britanniques
s'embarquent côté Est,
les Américains se concentrent
dans les ports de l'Ouest.
Désormais, ils ne quitteront
leur bâtiment que pour débarquer.
Les Canadiens
sous commandement britannique
et troisième forces alliées,
alignent pour leur part 21 000 hommes.
Le chargement de 20 000 véhicules,
tous entrés par le cul
dans le ventre des navires
pour mieux en sortir sur les plages,
constitue lui aussi
un prodigieux tour de force.
Sans compter les milliers
de tonnes d'approvisionnement
qui vont être transportées
dès les deux premiers jours.
Pour donner toutes les chances
à son attaque,
Eisenhower a dû tenir compte
de plusieurs paramètres.
Notamment l'obligation de faire coïncider
une nuit de clair de lune
pour mieux voir sans être vu,
et une marée
à mi-hauteur à l'aube, pour débarquer.
Début juin, seules les dates
du cinq, six ou sept conviennent.
Pour bénéficier de la surprise,
le plus tôt sera le mieux.
Ike décide que le débarquement
aura lieu le 5 juin.
Mais depuis quelques jours,
le temps se gâte.
Le 4 juin,
alors même que les premiers bâtiments
basés dans le nord de l'Angleterre
font route vers la Manche,
une tempête éclate.
Elle oblige Eisenhower à rappeler aux port
les bateaux déjà partis.
L'opération Overlord
est désormais menacée,
car les mouvements initiés
risquent d'alerter les Allemands.
Nuit et jour, Ike et ses collaborateurs
restent suspendus à la météo.
Elle n'annonce rien de bon,
si ce n'est un report
de deux semaines de l'opération.
Ce serait une catastrophe.
Il faudrait remotiver les hommes
et la campagne d'été
serait abrégée de quinze jours.
Dans les ports où Eisenhower
doit retarder le départ des navires
qui n'avaient pas encore pris la mer,
l'attente aussi est pénible,
qui vous fait tourner en rond
comme des crocodiles dans un marigot.
Ce 4 juin, le jeune Desmond O'Neill
est au travail,
au milieu de ses camarades
de la troisième division britannique,
sous un vent
qui n'a pas encore l'air de tomber.
« On était juste là, assis à bord, »
« n'ayant rien d'autre
à faire que manger ou fumer. »
« On ne manquait pas de vivres. »
« J'avais moi-même de quoi manger
pour dix hommes. »
« Il y avait comme un sentiment
d'amère désillusion. »
« Nous, nous ne savions toujours pas
où nous allions, »
« si ce n'est
qu'on devait traverser la Manche. »
« Plus tard, on nous a dit
que nous débarquerions à Lion-sur-Mer. »
« Ça ne disait rien à personne. »
C'est connu, les Canadiens
ont toujours eu le sens de la religion
pour y puiser sans doute
le secours dont ils auront bientôt besoin.
Jamais service religieux ne furent suivis
avec autant de ferveur
que ce dimanche 4 juin 1944,
dans tous les ports
du sud de l'Angleterre.
Côté américain,
on tente de rester efficace
car on sait que des hommes
qui s'épuisent à attendre
deviendront encore plus vulnérables
le jour venu.
Le 4 juin au soir.
Les prévisions météo
sont un peu moins pessimistes.
Elles prévoient une accalmie le lundi cinq
et le mardi 6 juin.
Cette nuit-là,
en une demi-heure,
Eisenhower prend une décision
qui met en jeu le sort du monde.
Ce sera le 6 juin 1944.
Dès le 5 juin,
l'énorme machine se met en marche.
L'Aviation alliée attaque
les régions et les villes
du nord et de l'ouest de la France
pour empêcher l'accès
de la Normandie aux Allemands.
Les Anglo-Américains
ne font pas dans la dentelle.
Trois jours durant,
la Normandie sera écrasée sous les bombes,
faisant presque 4 000 victimes.
Ces bombardements ont suscité
d'âpres discussions
entre Eisenhower et Churchill,
effrayé du poids de la haine
qui risque de s'accumuler
chez les Français.
À la surprise des Alliés,
la Résistance française a répondu :
« C'est la guerre.
Il faut admettre qu'il y aura des tués. »
Le 3 juin à Alger,
le général de Gaulle a transformé
le Comité français de libération nationale
en gouvernement provisoire
de la République française.
Jusqu'alors, il n'a pas eu son mot à dire.
Les Alliés ont tout caché aux Français.
Mais à l'heure
où s'annonce la libération du pays,
les Anglo-Américains ont besoin du général
pour s'assurer de l'entière coopération
de la population
et de la Résistance française.
Le 4 juin, convoqué par Churchill,
il est parti pour l'Angleterre,
bien décidé à se faire entendre.
Il refuse que les Alliés dictent leur loi.
Bien que ceux-ci ne lui confient pas
entièrement le pouvoir,
l'ombrageux général
consent à soutenir Overlord.
Le 5 juin, sur mer,
les manœuvres de diversion continuent.
Des dizaines de petits navires
font cap vers le nord du Havre.
Ils activent leurs cheminées
comme autant d'écrans de fumée.
Pour dissimuler leur importance véritable
et faire croire à un convoi
de gros navires traversant la Manche
vers un point situé nettement
au nord des plages normandes.
Le général Eisenhower a toujours considéré
que la place d'un chef
était auprès de ses hommes avant
et pendant la bataille.
Ce 5 juin en fin d'après-midi,
sur l'aérodrome de Greenham Common,
à quelques heures du décollage,
il rend visite aux hommes
de la 101ᵉ division aéroportée américaine.
Ils seront parmi les premiers
à atteindre le sol de France.
Derrière son sourire,
Ike a l'air un peu tendu.
Raison de plus
pour prendre une mine réjouie
et rassurer leur chef.
Ce jour-là, Eisenhower
reste jusqu'au bout,
jusqu'au décollage du dernier avion.
Un peu plus loin, à défaut d'être
encouragés par leur chef en personne,
leurs camarades parachutistes éclaireurs
se donnent du courage à leur manière.
Réels Peau-Rouge d'origine ou simple
mythe américain du guerrier indien,
leurs peintures de guerre
n'en permet pas moins
à ces Iroquois de 20 ans
de se chauffer à blanc.
Quand il n'est pas bariolé,
leur visage est passé au noir de fumée
pour être moins visible.
Outre leurs armes et parachutes,
ces hommes doivent aussi sauter
avec leurs émetteurs radio
pour signaler les zones balisées
sur lesquelles les planeurs qui suivront
déposeront le gros des troupes.
Trois types pour hisser un para
qui a 50 % de risques d'y rester
et qui le sait.
Ce même soir, Ike écrit une lettre
dans le cas où le débarquement
tournerait au désastre.
Elle prouve que les Alliés
ne sont sûrs de rien.
« Ma décision d'attaquer
à cette période et à cet endroit »
« était basée sur les meilleures
observations possibles », écrit-il.
« S'il y a eu des fautes ou des erreurs
commises lors de cette tentative, »
« j'en porte l'entière responsabilité. »
Depuis des semaines, en effet,
les Alliés peaufinent un plan
maintenant bien établi.
Dans la nuit du 5 au 6 juin,
les défenses côtières allemandes
devront être anéanties sous les bombes.
Avant que l'artillerie navale
ne pilonne à son tour à l'aube,
70 kilomètres de côtes.
Les Britanniques avec les Canadiens
se chargeront
du flanc droit de l'invasion.
Trois plages leur ont été assignées,
Sword, Juno et Gold.
Situées entre Ouistreham et Arromanches.
Les Américains s'occuperont
du flanc gauche,
les plages d'Omaha
et d'Utah leur ont été dévolues.
Les Britanniques devront s'emparer
de Caen au plus vite.
La ville commande en effet
un important nœud de communications
par où les Allemands
peuvent acheminer leurs renforts.
Elle ouvre surtout sur une plaine qui doit
garantir aux blindés alliés de se déployer
et aux avions de se poser
sur des aérodromes provisoires.
Les Américains devront remonter
vers Cherbourg,
qu'ils ont prévu
de prendre huit jours plus tard
pour pouvoir débarquer
les centaines de milliers d'hommes
et tout le matériel nécessaire
à la suite de l'offensive.
Le 6 juin,
à partir de 3 h 15 du matin,
les bombardiers alliés commencent
à pilonner les positions allemandes
dans tous les secteurs du débarquement.
À l'aube, l'artillerie navale alliée
prend le relais
afin de pulvériser le mur de l'Atlantique.
La plage d'Omaha, près du Cotentin,
doit ouvrir le bal.
Les Américains doivent s'en emparer
pour ensuite faire la jonction
avec leurs camarades d'Utah.
Arrivés trop tôt
ou trop tard sur les lieux,
les bombardements aériens
ont manqué leur cible.
L'artillerie navale n'a pas fait mieux.
L'heure précoce du débarquement,
déterminée par la marée,
ne lui a pas laissé le temps
de mener à bien le pilonnage prévu.
Le gros de l'attaque échoit aux GI's
de la célèbre Big Red One,
unité expérimentée.
Mais on leur a adjoint le 116ᵉ bataillon
composé de jeunes boys
qui n'ont encore jamais connu
l'épreuve du feu.
Pour éviter les tirs ennemis,
les barges ont été mises à l'eau
trop loin des côtes,
au milieu d'une mer agitée.
Les hommes s'y entassent,
chargés comme des mules.
« Quand le bruit du premier éclat
percute nos oreilles, »
« on se jette à plat ventre
dans les vomissures »
« sans plus surveiller la côte
qui s'approche »,
raconte Robert Capa,
seul photographe présent ce jour-là.
À peine sur la plage,
les hommes sont cueillis
par une défense allemande quasi intacte
qui les tire comme des lapins.
Le vent a fait monter la mer
plus vite que prévu.
Les vagues d'assaut suivantes
s'empale sur les obstacles de Rommel,
obligeant les hommes
à débarquer dans une eau profonde.
Incapables d'avancer.
Tous se regroupe au centre de la plage,
réduits à envoyer le même message
d'une effroyable concision :
« Sommes cloués sur place
par artillerie ennemie. »
Crucifiez plutôt.
Comme le montrent
les rares clichés restant de Capa.
Tous les autres
ayant été accidentellement détruits.
Un courant violent
déporte les embarcations.
Les hommes se noient,
entraînés par la charge de leur matériel.
La mer est rouge.
Rouge comme Omaha la sanglante
où les hommes sont en perdition.
Le commandement américain
envisage de stopper l'offensive.
Ce choix désespéré signifierait l'abandon
des troupes déjà débarquées.
Les morts et les blessés
se comptent déjà par centaines.
Leur sacrifice aurait été vain.
L'arrêt des opérations laisserait aussi
ouverte une énorme brèche
sur la continuité du front allié,
alors même
que la gigantesque machine de guerre
est lancée à plein régime.
En effet, ce 6 juin,
le jour maintenant levé,
dévoile l'armada de 7 000 navires
qui s'approchent des côtes normandes.
Comme toujours Ike n'est pas loin.
À 9 h 45, il s'adresse au monde
et aux siens par la voix de la BBC.
Que tous les hommes qui aiment
la liberté soient des nôtres
Que rien n'ébranle votre foi.
Rien n'arrêtera nos coups.
Ensemble, nous vaincrons.
Sur un front de 70 kilomètres,
il y a pratiquement un bateau
tous les 250 mètres
couverts par 11 000 avions.
Tous sont munis de bandes blanches
pour permettre à l'artillerie alliée
de les identifier
et de ne pas tirer sur les appareils amis.
Heureusement,
tous les secteurs de la côte
ne ressemblent pas à celui d'Omaha.
D'autant que les Allemands,
égarés par la désinformation des alliés,
croient toujours à une attaque
sur le Pas-de-Calais
et peinent à s'organiser.
Il a bon dos
l'infranchissable mur de l'Atlantique.
De même, leurs DCA
qui s'épuisent à tourner en rond.
Ce jour-là, l'aviation alliée
effectue quelques 10 000 sorties.
Insensible aux fleurets
mouchetés d'une défense allemande
souvent dépassée.
Tandis que les B26 déversent leurs
dernières bombes à l'intérieur des terres,
les avions d'attaque
entrent à leur tour en action.
Les défenses côtières
ne sont pas les seules frappées.
Les bases aériennes
sont aussi visées,
afin de clouer au sol
ce qu'il reste de l'aviation ennemie.
Les nœuds de communications,
routes, ponts, lignes de chemin de fer
sont systématiquement pilonnés.
La résistance française
n'est pas en reste,
qui après la phase de renseignement
et sabotage, passe maintenant à l'attaque
et cherche à empêcher les Allemands
d'acheminer leurs renforts sur le front.
Du coup, sous l'action conjuguée
des Alliés et des Résistants,
les troupes allemandes
appelées de Bretagne
et du sud de la Loire peinent à arriver.
Rommel avait raison,
lui qui voulait dès le départ
concentrer les troupes
aux abords des plages
pour arrêter les assaillants.
La troisième division britannique
fait cap sur la plage de Sword.
Elle doit d'abord neutraliser
les défenses de Ouistreham
et s'emparer de Caen le jour même.
Le 45ᵉ royal commando écossais,
filmé par leur compatriote,
le sergent Ian Grant
de débarquer à Ouistreham.
« Cette fois, on y était », raconte Grant.
« J'ai tout de suite filmé
cette gigantesque armada »
« comme je le pouvais. »
« Car j'étais quasiment
au niveau de la mer. »
« On nous avait donné de sacrées rations
et des pilules contre le mal de mer. »
« Mais avec ces effluves de diesel,
la plupart d'entre nous, »
« même les plus forts, étaient malades. »
« Le ciel était noir d'avions. »
« On avait dit à certains
de passer à basse altitude »
« tandis qu'on nous signalait par
haut parleurs les marques spécifiques »
« qui distinguaient les avions amis. »
« On avait dit aux hommes
d'ignorer le plus possible les caméras. »
« C'étaient des acteurs naturels. »
« Plongés dans leurs pensées,
vivant leur expérience propre. »
« Je n'avais pas peur car il n'y avait
aucune crainte sur leur visage. »
« Juste le désir de sortir
de ce satané bateau
qui leur donnait le mal de mer. »
« Plus on s'approchait de la plage,
plus le vacarme devenait assourdissant. »
« Dans la précipitation,
une rampe s'est cassée. »
« Tout le monde a convergé
vers la même passerelle. »
« Restait à descendre du mieux possible. »
« Votre sac sur le dos
vous poussait vers le bas. »
Grant et les siens
ont été préservés du premier assaut.
Pour eux, le plus dur commence,
faire la jonction avec les troupes
parachutées derrière les lignes ennemies.
Un autre caméraman est déjà sur Sword.
Le plus jeune d'entre eux,
le sergent O'Neill,
arrivé 45 minutes avant Grant.
C'est lui qui filme
les derniers soubresauts de la bataille.
« Au milieu d'une fumée grise
tout semblait irréel. »
« Ce n'était pas une bataille telle
qu'on pouvait l'imaginer »
« ou la voir dans les films. »
« Les sorties de la plage
étaient souvent engorgées. »
« On ne pouvait guère se dégager. »
« J'ai suivi un peloton d'infanterie
qui essayait aussi de s'extraire ».
Quand soudain,
sa caméra tressaute.
Il est touché à son tour.
Le temps de tourner encore quelques plans
avec son bras valide
et il est rapatrié en Angleterre le soir
même pour y être soigné.
Au revoir jeune O'Neill et bravo
à tous tes camarades
qui ce jour-là ont conquis
la plage de Sword
au prix de 600 tués et blessés.
Tous perdus dans la masse de ces inconnus
dont la plupart avaient à peine 20 ans.
Tandis que maintenant
nombre d'Allemands faits prisonniers
sont rassemblés sur les plages.
À quelques kilomètres
de Sword, la plage de Juno
en secteur canadien.
Objectif, la prise
de Carpiquet, l'aéroport de Caen.
Qu'ont-ils en tête, ces jeunes soldats
qui ont parcouru 8 000 kilomètres
pour venir débarquer à Bernières,
petite station inconnue
de la côte normande.
Ici, c'est bien la première vague
d'assaut qui est filmée.
La seule de tout le débarquement,
mais par une caméra automatique
arrimée au bastingage.
Pourtant, même l’œil froid
d'une caméra mécanique
ne saurait tout ignorer d'un geste humain.
Bientôt apparaît
la toute première maison française
libérée en Normandie.
Elle coûte la vie à une centaine d'hommes
que les caméramen alliés ont reçu
l'ordre de ne pas trop montrer.
Plutôt donner à voir
les premiers prisonniers allemands
et la colère d'un patriote
français à leur égard.
La reddition des Allemands
ne peut occulter
les difficultés rencontrées par les hommes
sur les plages de Juno,
où une mer mauvaise complique
le débarquement
et l'arrivée des deuxième vagues d'assaut.
Bilan, 300 jeunes Canadiens tués.
Leur sacrifice n'a pas été vain.
La plage conquise, leurs camarades vivants
s'avancent sur plusieurs kilomètres
à l'intérieur des terres vers Caen.
Déjà leur première récompense.
Ces jeunes Françaises
ravies de voir leur pays libéré
par des hommes
dont beaucoup parlent français.
Même s'ils ont un accent bizarre.
Pourtant à Portsmouth, au QG des Alliés,
et malgré le sourire
de l'amiral anglais Ramsey,
fier du rôle de sa flotte,
le général Eisenhower
semble toujours soucieux.
Depuis le début de la matinée,
les messages se succèdent,
tantôt alarmants comme à Omaha,
tantôt encourageants comme à Utah
ou dans le secteur britannique.
À voir le visage d'Eisenhower,
on se dit cependant qu'à cette heure,
rien n'est encore joué.
En effet, six heures
après avoir débarqué à Omaha,
les boys sont toujours bloqués
au pied de la falaise.
Les Américains
privilégient toujours les hommes,
quel que soit
le surcroît d'intendance nécessaire.
Même les premières vagues d'assaut
sont pourvues d'une structure
médicale bien rodée,
avec médecins et infirmiers,
pour prendre en charge
au plus vite les blessés,
fussent-ils des ennemis.
Jamais les secours
n'auront été plus utiles
que sur Omaha la sanglante.
Où s'entassent désormais morts
et quelques prisonniers.
3 000 Américains perdus,
sur la plus meurtrière
des cinq plages du débarquement.
Pourtant, en fin de journée,
le soleil revenu
et après que les premières lignes aient
enfin réussi à s'extraire de la nasse,
l'arrivée des troupes reprend sur Omaha.
Cette fois, on peut dire
que le débarquement a réussi.
Reste maintenant à gagner
la prochaine bataille,
celle de la Normandie et de la France.
Le général Montgomery
arrive deux jours plus tard.
Il a de quoi être soucieux.
Toujours désireux de disposer d'un rapport
de force écrasant en sa faveur
avant d'agir,
il a tardé à mettre ses blindés en action.
Il n'a pas réussi à s'emparer de Caen
comme il devait le faire
dès le premier jour.
De plus, ses troupes,
soulagées d'avoir réussi à débarquer
sans trop de casse,
font preuve maintenant,
d'un certain manque de mordant.
Leurs caméramen en témoignent
à leur façon, qui se baladent,
découvrant ces premiers
drôles de français.
Que l'on fait aussi poser
pour les besoins de la cause,
même si ceux-là ont plutôt l'air
de s'y prêter volontiers.
Ce 8 juin, Norman Clague,
l'homme au clap,
nous montre déjà
ces premiers moments d'apaisement
où prisonniers et blessés de la Wehrmacht
n'ont plus
à craindre leurs ennemis d'hier.
Cinq jours encore
et Clague sera tué sous le feu allemand.
Chez lui, compassion et morbidité
n'auront jamais été très éloignées.
Mais ces images montrent
bien aussi le relâchement,
qui, au lendemain D-DAY,
s'est emparé des Anglais.
Un ralentissement
dont les Allemands vont profiter.
Si les forces allemandes
maintenues à l'arrière du front
conformément aux directives de Rundstedt,
n'ont pu refouler les Alliés à la mer,
elles réagissent maintenant.
Deux divisions blindées, dont la fameuse
12ᵉ Panzer Hitlerjugend SS,
contre-attaquent
les 7, 8 et 9 juin.
Elles barrent la route de Caen
aux Britanniques et aux Canadiens.
Les Allemands organisent aussi
la défense de la ville
depuis l'extérieur de la cité.
Du coup, les bombardements sur Caen
s'avèrent inopérants.
Ils permettent par
contre à la propagande allemande
de montrer ses soldats
partager le sort des habitants.
La Wehrmacht reste maîtresse de la ville,
tandis que pour les premiers réfugiés,
l'approche des libérateurs
sonne comme un départ.
La contre-attaque allemande a aussi isolé
certaines troupes aéroportées alliées.
Souvent larguées de manière imprécise,
elles n'ont pas réussi la jonction
avec leurs camarades venus de la mer.
Beaucoup sont capturés,
mais peu semblent résignés.
Les troupes aéroportées américaines
ont perdu, pour leur part,
plus de la moitié de leur matériel
et un soldat sur cinq.
Tous ces hommes ont payé cher
l'honneur d'être les premiers
à fouler le sol de France.
Leur trop grande dispersion
a eu cependant le mérite
d'ajouter à la confusion des Allemands,
leur faisant croire à un largage
beaucoup plus important qu'en réalité.
Et maintenant ce sont ceux
de la 81ᵉ qui rejoignent la Terre.
Avant que leurs camarades
ne leur rendent un dernier hommage.
[English spoken audio]
Prêt, en joue, feu.
En joue, feu.
Le 9 juin, les Américains s'emparent
de la petite ville d'Isigny.
Elle aussi rageusement bombardée,
pour en déloger définitivement
les Allemands.
Ce verrou empêchait les forces d'Omaha
et d'Utah de se rejoindre
pour se lancer ensuite sur Cherbourg.
Isigny prise, le front allié
désormais réuni
s'étend sur 100 kilomètres de Ouistreham,
à la base de la péninsule du Cotentin.
Par-delà les gravats,
vers où regardent-ils
ces habitants d'Isigny ?
Peut-être plus loin, vers la mer,
où un pavillon français
flotte enfin sur la Manche.
Les Alliés, solidement
établis sur les côtes,
il est temps de faire venir
le général de Gaulle,
chef du gouvernement provisoire.
Charles de Gaulle
n'a jamais besoin qu'on l'aide.
Surtout lorsqu'il retrouve enfin la France
à Courseulles, après quatre années d'exil.
La veille, Churchill,
toujours un peu méfiant,
a écrit à Montgomery :
« Je dois vous infliger une visite
du général de Gaulle. »
« Je ne pense pas que vous deviez
l'accueillir sur la plage. »
« Il sera bien suffisant
qu'il arrive à votre quartier général. »
De Gaulle n'a qu'une journée
à passer en France.
Lui aussi est pressé.
Le temps de dire à Montgomery
ce qu'il a envie d'entendre,
l'Anglais lui cède enfin la vedette.
Monti charge aussi Norman Johnson,
son propre caméraman,
de suivre De Gaulle,
si ce n'est de l'épier.
Bien qu'habitué aux coquetteries
de son chef,
Johnson sent tout de suite
que le Français est une good story.
« Difficile de le suivre », dira-t-il.
Heureusement, il était grand.
Il ne changeait guère d'expression,
toujours sérieux.
Mais il créait l'ambiance.
Il ignorait toujours la caméra,
ou du moins, il semblait l'ignorer.
Bref, déjà une graine de star.
À Bayeux, partout des gens heureux
de voir enfin des hommes qui ne sont pas
sous la botte allemande,
signe d'une nouvelle
souveraineté française.
D'autant que le Général tient
ostensiblement à se montrer avec les siens
et des hommes de la Résistance
sans aucun Anglo-Américain.
Avant de se diriger vers la mairie
où il installe ses hommes,
sans en référer aux Alliés.
Il leur dénie toute responsabilité
dans les choix politiques de la France
et les oblige à reconnaître de fait
son pouvoir sur le terrain.
Si les hommes n'ont pas eu besoin
de ports pour débarquer,
ils ont besoin maintenant
de leurs ports artificiels
pour continuer la bataille.
Car il faut bien que la logistique
soutienne les centaines
de milliers de soldats alliés.
Chaque jour, 250 à 200 bâtiments
déversent quelque 7 000 véhicules,
15 000 tonnes de ravitaillement
et des milliers d'hommes
dans le port d'Arromanches, côté anglais,
et dans celui d'Omaha, côté américain.
Mais bientôt le temps se gâte et risque
encore une fois de tout compromettre.
Jamais depuis 40 ans
une telle tourmente en Normandie,
avec à l'intérieur
des aires de mouillage,
des bateaux devenus des chiens fous.
Le rempart des caissons s'avère incapable
de résister au cataclysme.
Pire, certains dérivent,
laissant s'engouffrer les flots.
Quai de déchargement
et passerelle flottante se disloquent,
balayés
comme des fétus de paille.
La tempête va durer quatre longs jours
qui interrompent l'approvisionnement
et le renfort des troupes.
Le matin du 23 juin
dévoile le triste spectacle des navires
et des épaves
qui, par centaines, jonchent les plages.
Si les ingénieurs anglais
réparent vite Arromanches,
le port des Américains à Omaha
demeure hors d'usage.
Ils ont dix jours de retard
sur leurs plans.
Il leur faut s'emparer au plus vite
du port en eaux profondes de Cherbourg.
Bien qu'encerclée, la ville est toujours
aux mains des Allemands.
Le 26 juin, enfin, l'infanterie américaine
pénètre dans les faubourgs de Cherbourg.
Ce même jour devant une presse
qu'il ne semble guère apprécier,
le général von Schlieben,
commandant de la garnison, se rend.
Si ce colosse sait s'essuyer les pieds
devant son vainqueur,
le jeune général Collins,
l'Allemand s'assoit aussi
sur son serment fait à Hitler
de préférer la mort
à une honteuse reddition.
Comble de flétrissure,
Schlieben s'est soumis
avant même ses hommes
qui, le lendemain, se rendent à leur tour.
Les Américains
ne sont pas toujours des tendres,
ce qui peut se comprendre.
Depuis le jour J,
ils ont déjà perdu 22 000 hommes.
À voir la moyenne d'âge
des prisonniers vieux ou très jeunes,
on constate le délabrement
de la Wehrmacht,
dont les troupes les plus aguerries
sont surtout mobilisées
à l'Est pour combattre l'Armée rouge.
36 000 prisonniers à Cherbourg.
Chiffre énorme au regard de ce que peut
capter une caméra.
Sauf qu'elle aussi parfois étonne
et frappe.
Avec la prise de Cherbourg
s'écroule l'une des dernières pièces
du mythique Mur de l'Atlantique.
Même si, contrairement à leurs hommes,
une certaine morgue se lit toujours sur
le visage des officiers faits prisonniers.
Mais peut-être aussi une certaine honte.
Après Cherbourg,
Hitler procède à une reprise en main
de l'armée allemande sur le front Ouest.
Il a limogé Von Rundstedt,
qui avait suggéré de faire la paix
et l'a remplacé par Von Kluge,
plus docile.
Rommel, accablé
par le jusqu'auboutisme du Führer, lui,
sait qu'il ne reste
au mieux qu'à retarder le désastre.
Eisenhower, de son côté,
est aussi inquiet.
Certes, les Américains
ont conquis Cherbourg,
mais Montgomery
n'a toujours pas pris Caen
à partir de laquelle
il devait percer les lignes allemandes.
Installée à l'intérieur des terres,
la Wehrmacht a l'avantage de l'espace
avec les possibilités de ravitaillement
et de renfort qu'elle confère,
alors que les Alliés restent toujours
enfermés le long des côtes de la Manche.
Dès lors, les Américains
n'ont d'autre choix
que de tenter de percer
le front ennemi dans le Cotentin.
Pas facile à faire
dans une région de bocages
où les haies avantages la défense.
Voir sans être vu,
un atout pour l'ennemi dans cette bataille
à laquelle les boys ne sont pas préparés.
Dans ce labyrinthe en damier,
quelques combattants résolus
peuvent arrêter un bataillon.
Et quand ils doivent
céder un de ces champs carrés,
suffit qu'ils reviennent ensuite
par les côtés.
Les chars américains,
obligés d'emprunter les routes
et les chemins sont des cibles faciles.
Ils le sont encore quand ils doivent
franchir les levées de terre
à la base des haies.
Et qu'ils offrent aux ennemis
leurs ventres dépourvus de blindage.
Bilan de ces pièges,
des milliers de GI's tués
et une percée ratée dans ce maudit bocage.
A goddamn country.
Une saleté de pays.
Cette fois, les Anglais,
devant les difficultés des Américains,
se doivent d'en finir
rapidement avec Caen.
Montgomery décide enfin
d'employer les grands moyens.
Il a demandé le renfort de l'aviation.
Plus de 2 500 tonnes de bombes
sont déversées sur la ville.
Certains avancent, d'autres partent.
À quoi bon se regarder,
c'est comme ça.
Après deux jours de combats acharnés,
115 000 anglais pénètrent à l'Est de Caen
aux trois quarts détruite.
Le 13 juillet, Montgomery
arrive à son tour.
Il lui aura fallu plus d'un mois
pour s'emparer d'une partie de Caen
qu'il espérait prendre dès le premier jour
et d'où devait partir
la percée des Alliés.
Décidément, au royaume des aveugles,
les borgnes sont rois.
Les habitants ont beau hisser le drapeau
à Croix de Lorraine,
seule une partie de la ville est prise.
Ce qui n'empêche pas
la propagande anglaise
de faire croire qu'entre habitants
de la ville aux 100 clochers
et soldats britanniques, on trinque.
Au revoir et merci encore.
Je vous en prie,
tout le plaisir est pour moi.
Pareils bombardements
et leurs 2 000 morts,
alors même que les défenses allemandes
étaient situées hors de la ville,
étaient-ils nécessaires ?
Le débat, encore aujourd'hui,
reste ouvert.
Chacun réagit comme il peut.
Qui étais-tu, toi, l'Allemand jouant
au même moment de l'orgue
dans cette église normande en ruine ?
Un fou ?
Un salaud de boche ?
Un Allemand mélomane ?
Ou un simple soldat perdu d'Hitler,
désormais dépassé
par le délire de son chef,
et qui essaie d'oublier
cette atmosphère de fin du monde.
Quelques jours
plus tard, Winston Churchill,
le Premier ministre anglais,
débarque à son tour.
Il tient à se rendre compte en personne
de l'état des opérations
dans le secteur de Caen.
Mais Montgomery a beau
jouer les guides touristiques,
c'est plus sa voiture
qu'il domine que la plaine de Caen,
encore aux mains de la Wehrmacht.
Dix jours après la prise de la ville,
les Anglais n'ont toujours pas percé
les lignes allemandes
et ce n'est pas l'agitation de Churchill
qui y change quelque chose.
Pour Eisenhower,
qui espérait une rupture du front ennemi
dans ce secteur,
c'est une déception totale
compte tenu des moyens énormes déployés.
Le commandant en chef fait dorénavant
de plus en plus confiance
au discret général
trois étoiles, Omar Bradley,
qui a organisé le débarquement
d'Omaha et d'Utah
avant d'aller s'emparer de Cherbourg.
Eisenhower apprécie son calme,
sa lucidité et son efficacité.
Bradley pense que la percée du front
ennemi devra se faire par les Américains
et dans le Cotentin.
Nom de code de son opération, Cobra.
Comme un serpent qui se détend
et vous saute à la gueule.
Pour aider les hommes
à se dégager du bocage,
Bradley a prévu d'écraser d'abord
sous les bombes les positions allemandes
sur la ligne de front
qui sépare les deux ennemis.
La percée une fois effectuée,
ses troupes s'élanceront simultanément
vers la Bretagne
ainsi que vers la Seine et la Loire.
Le 25 juillet, l'aviation alliée attaque
la route entre Saint Loup et Perrier
où les deux armées sont au contact.
La fameuse division blindée
du général Lehr,
le second du maréchal Rommel,
est anéantie sous les bombes.
À partir de ce périmètre d'enfer,
les hommes peuvent enfin sortir du bocage.
Il crée ce break out, cette brèche
dans le front ennemi longtemps attendue.
En plus, la pêche est bonne
à voir tous ceux qui se rendent.
Même si parfois elle ramasse
quelques menus fretins.
Dans ce bestiaire
qu'est devenu la Normandie,
les chars sont désormais équipés de lames
pour cisailler les haies
et franchir les derniers
kilomètres de bocage.
Avant même la fin juillet,
la percée réussie,
les blindés américains
atteignent Coutances,
Avranches
et Granville, derniers ports normands
avant la Bretagne.
Début août,
la deuxième division blindée française
débarque à son tour à Utah Beach.
Depuis des mois, des années,
ces Français avaient tout quitté
pour combattre les Allemands
et les Italiens en Afrique.
Tandis qu'ils s'apprêtent,
cette fois en vainqueurs
à fouler à nouveau
leur cher sol de France.
À leur tête, le général Leclerc,
sec comme sa canne,
mais aussi valeureux que droit.
Tout aurait dû porter cet aristocrate
du côté de Vichy,
mais il a choisi de suivre
de Gaulle dès juin 40.
Et maintenant
c'est en libérateur qu'il débarque.
Sa division est intégrée
à la troisième armée américaine,
avec laquelle elle va enfin pouvoir
participer aux opérations
sur le sol national.
Quartier général de Bradley.
Sous les objectifs
du cinéaste américain George Stevens
Montgomery jamais insensible aux caméras
décor quelques soldats Yankee.
Ça, il sait bien faire.
Poussé par Eisenhower,
l'Anglais a accepté
de laisser la direction
de la bataille finale aux Américains.
Pour la mener à bien,
Bradley compte aussi
sur un certain général Patton.
L'homme au pistolet
à la crosse d'ivoire est un fonceur.
« Au premier pet de travers, on s'attend
à ce que je les sorte de leur merde »,
a-t-il coutume de dire.
Ça tombe bien.
Au petit matin, les Allemands tentent
une opération de la dernière chance.
Depuis la plaine de Caen,
ils lancent une contre-attaque à Mortain,
espérant rejeter les Alliés à la mer.
L'offensive planifiée
par Hitler en personne
est aussitôt enrayée par les Typhoon
lance-roquettes des Alliés.
Cette affaire
n'avait aucune chance de succès,
écrira Von Kluge avant de se suicider.
Elle aura été
la dernière offensive allemande.
Pire encore, à Mortain, Bradley a laissé
volontairement l'ennemi
s'enfoncer dans le flanc allié.
Désormais, les Allemands sont coincés
entre les Américains au Sud,
et les Britanniques au Nord.
Bradley va pouvoir enfin effectuer
la manœuvre à laquelle
il pense depuis longtemps.
Prendre l'ennemi en tenaille
entre les divisions britanniques
venues de la plaine de Caen
et les armées américaines plus au sud.
Avant que les deux mâchoires de son piège
se referme entre Argentan et Falaise,
sur une Wehrmacht en retraite.
Sitôt la contre-offensive allemande
stoppée à Mortain,
Patton et ses divisions se sont élancés
vers Le Mans en direction de Paris.
Mais maintenant une partie d'entre
elles bifurque vers Argentan
et entreprennent
le large mouvement de faux
qui encercle les Allemands.
Tandis qu'au Nord, les Anglo-Canadiens
opèrent la jonction entre alliés.
La Wehrmacht a été laminée
et Eisenhower pourra écrire :
« Le champ de bataille de Falaise,
fut sans conteste, »
« l'un des plus grands champs de tuerie »
« qu'aucun secteur de la guerre
eût jamais connu. »
« C'était un spectacle que seule
la plume d'un Dante eût pu décrire. »
« On pouvait avancer
sur des centaines de mètres »
« sans interruption,
en ne marchant littéralement »
« que sur des chairs mortes
et pourrissantes. »
5 000 6 000 morts du côté allemand.
À voir la tête
de ceux qui ont été capturés,
on sent qu'Ike n'a pas exagéré.
Il faudra plusieurs jours pour évacuer
les 30 à 40 000 prisonniers de Falaise.
Pour eux, la captivité est une victoire,
celle de la vie sur la mort.
La Wehrmacht a mobilisé de nombreux hommes
dans les pays qu'elle occupe.
Tous n'ont pas eu à cœur
de défendre leur Reich jusqu'au trépas.
Cette fois,
c'en est fini de l'Allemagne en Normandie.
Falaise terminé
et ses prisonniers évacués,
les armées de Patton ont franchi
la Seine et la Loire.
Dès lors, Eisenhower a atteint les
deux limites fixées par le plan Overlord.
Il désire passer maintenant
à l'étape suivante.
La poussée vers le Reich.
Le 19 août,
un rideau de fumée plane sur Paris.
Au sol, à l'approche des Alliés,
la ville s'est insurgée.
C'est d'abord et surtout la Wehrmacht
qui décide d'abandonner Paris
à regarder vue du ciel ses convois
systématiquement évacuer la ville
en direction de l'Est, sans trop
se soucier des barricades érigées.
Éternelles mêmes images et unique
action réelle à avoir été filmée.
Cinq Allemands en flammes.
Ce qui n'ôte rien à ces hommes
qui se sont insurgés
avant l'arrivée des Alliés et aux dizaines
d'entre eux qui sont morts
en combattant
l'armée allemande en déroute.
Le lendemain, de Gaulle
déboule chez Eisenhower.
Ike veut éviter de faire de Paris
un autre champ de bataille.
Il préfère encercler la capitale
pour forcer les Allemands à se rendre
et cueillir la ville comme un fruit mûr.
C'est compter
sans l'éloquence du français
qui persuade l'Américain
de se lancer sur la ville
pour éviter un possible bain de sang
et neutraliser l'ascendant des résistants
communistes à Paris.
Ike se laisse convaincre
et Bradley accepte
de détacher la deuxième DB de Leclerc
qui s'était illustrée à Falaise,
pour qu'elle entre la première dans Paris
et y reçoivent
la capitulation allemande.
Après quelques combats sévères
au sud de la capitale,
dès la proche banlieue,
le ciel est déjà bleu.
Les femmes souvent en rouge,
les hommes en chemise blanche
et le monde en tricolore.
Pour accueillir les premiers Leclerc Boys
aux portes de Paris.
Et maintenant, dans la ville même,
la liesse ne demande
qu'à se muer en ivresse.
Ce jour-là,
l'homme du 18 juin a gagné son pari.
Le miracle a eu lieu.
La France écrasée et humiliée en 40
est bel et bien du côté des vainqueurs.
Dès lors, place à l'historique cortège
des Champs Élysées qui assoit sa légende.
Mais c'est là une histoire bien française.
La nôtre se termine le lendemain,
sur une place
de la Concorde moins magique.
À la tête d'un pays
à l'avenir politique encore incertain,
De Gaulle a demandé à Eisenhower
de conforter son autorité
aux yeux des Français.
L'Américain y consent volontiers
et le général Bradley n'est pas en reste.
Mais ce n'est pas sa seule modestie
qui le tient en retrait.
Tandis que de Gaulle
est placé au centre,
Eisenhower a tenu
à faire défiler devant le Français
les troupes U.S qui vont poursuivre
le combat contre le Reich.
Les Américains savent que dans le monde
bipolaire d'après guerre qui se prépare,
ils auront besoin de la France
à leurs côtés en Europe.
Notre histoire aura été haute en couleur,
à partir d'images d'origine,
souvent en noir et blanc.
Mais après tout,
couleur ou noir et blanc, qu'importe,
puisque chacune
nous aura montré à sa manière
le destin de tous ces hommes
du débarquement.
Si souvent confondus dans la masse.
Qui étais-tu, perdu parmi les tiens,
l'homme qui maintenant se retourne.
Qui que tu sois, à jamais, merci à toi.